ouais si michel pérat
michel peyrard bonsoir pense pas vous
êtes grand reporter à paris match et
vous couvrez depuis 15 ans tous les
conflits de la planète du nicaragua à
l'afghanistan en passant par la
tchétchénie et le 9 octobre 2001 deux
jours après le début des frappes
américaines en afghanistan
vous êtes arrêté par les talibans
accusés d'espionnage et vous encourez la
peine de mort vous serez emprisonné 26
jours avant d'être libérée et d'y
retourner pour retrouver votre géôliers
celui qui vous a sauvé la vie et
découvrir que vous aviez en fait échappé
de justesse à la mort
et puis aussi on en parlera qu'oussama
ben laden que les américains cherchaient
par tous était en fait tranquillement à
djalalabad
à moins d'un kilomètre de votre prison
voilà vous raconter tout ça dans un
livre qui paraît chez pauvert qui
s'appelle poste numéro trois hôtes des
talibans par michel perrin
michel bérard merci d'avoir choisi tout
le monde en parle pour en parler
interview vérité alors le 8 octobre à la
veille de votre capture vous êtes à
peshawar vous regardez des télévisions
des images de la guerre et vous dites
c'est très bien écrit le bouquin vous
dit d'emblée j'ai détesté cette guerre
si discourtoise qu'elle s'invite et un
dimanche soir veille de bouclage il n'ya
pas pire il ya partir parce qu'on n'a
pas le temps on n'a pas le temps de
travailler
alors votre bouquin c'est une réflexion
sur la guerre aussi vous dites j'aime
couvrir la guerre j'en aime les mauvais
goût les cadavres exhibé il ya un
plaisir à couvrir la guerre moi je
trouve que dans le dans la guerre il y a
il ya une des sociétés qui se dégage des
décotes des usages nos sociétés
occidentales sont réfugiés sont deux
sont très codifié dans la guerre souvent
les gens ne se la joue plus besoin et
plus la peine de sa jouer parce que la
vie est par essence éphémère donc les
masques tombent
j'ai l'impression parfois que le centre
de gravité du mas des places et j'aime
la vérité des gens à ce moment là dans
la guerre se donne de l'intensité à la
vie c'est ça qui vous fascine même les
journalistes trouvent leur compte dans
leur guerre dans la guerre c'est pas la
peine de se raconter des histoires on
aime ça ouais
et puis à cette idée d'aller voir
soi-même c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
les états majors organise des voyages 1
ce qu'on appelle le pool c'est à dire
pour un certain nombre de journalistes
et les trimbale comme ça ils leur
montrent ce qu'ils veulent bien leur
montrer et vous pendant la guerre du
koweït avec des copains vous aviez fait
un anti poule qui s'appelait fuck de
poule et et vous y alliez sens sans être
guidé par les militaires par les
militaires américains et alors il ya un
truc et ordinaire quand vous êtes arrivé
à koweït city s'étaient déguisés en
militaires devaient arriver avant le
pool de journalistes et vous êtes
découvert toutes les supercheries qui
était monté à l' usage des journalistes
où effectivement nous quand on est
arrivé on n'a pas découvert la quatrième
armée du monde qu'on nous vendait le
package package médiatique des
américains nous disait que c'était on
allez avant on allait voir ce qu'on
allait voir c'est adolf hitler avait pas
que saddam hussein
l'amérique a toujours eu des s'attend
donc ça a été noriega était kadhafi
puisse arrêter saddam hussein je crois
que l'amérique par définition a besoin
d'eux a besoin de se découvrir comme ça
d annie à noter d'ailleurs que ce sont
souvent d'anciens amis de l'orgue envoyé
l'armée irakienne soit disant la
quatrième armée du monde en fait vous
découvrez que c'est dégueu comme vous
dites dans votre book à des arbres en
revanche des armes et démotivés et puis
avait aussi une fausse salle de
supplices qui avait été montée à usage
des journalistes sert lorsqu'on est
arrivé à koweit city on a découvert à
l'hôpital moubarak du centre ville une
une morgue où il y avait des gens qui
avaient été supplie le supplie supplicié
et torturé à l'acide
il y avait huit ou une dizaine de
cadavres je crois
trois ou quatre jours après tout ça
avait été organisée pour les besoins du
pool pour montrer à la presse américaine
et acier annan en particulier à quel
point saddam hussein était un set était
s'attend alors à peshawar c'est pas en
militaires que vous utilisez cette fois
c'est un talibane c'est à dire que vous
essayez une burqa alors c'est très
intéressant d'ailleurs parce que vous
souhaitez porter une burqa et vous dites
que d'abord cette vision effectivement
grillagé et en plus elles n'ont pas le
droit de tourner la tête à droite ou à
gauche parce que finalement elle doit
pas regarder l'homme
donc elles sont un peu comme des chevaux
qui auraient désormais fière qui
auraient des ornières
elles n'ont pas le droit d'avoir un
regard pour leurs geôliers pour les
hommes
il ya effectivement beaucoup d'accidents
par exemple sur les sur les routes en
afghanistan parce que d'une part le
quadrillage et limites
et quand la vision et d'autre part ils
peuvent pas tourner la tête oui alors
vous faites un essai vous faites une
incurie fanchone à vous partez du plaqué
sens d'un afghanistan dans une ville et
chapelles rost qui est très important
des places-fortes stratégique des
taliban à la vous gérer ça marche
et là vous vous dites ça y est
maintenant je vais toujours habillé en
ont-elles iban je vais aller à kaboul
mais vous avez comme un pressentiment
c'est une espèce de prévention 1
je me sens pas ce matin là il ya une
succession d'événements d un confrère
pakistanais qui devait nous accompagner
qui est arrêté ensuite on a plus le bon
chauffeur
on a une espèce de pleutres de
chauffeurs lequel je n'ai aucune
confiance et j'aurais dû m'écouter à ce
moment là effectivement lors à ce moment
là où il ya une rivière a passé il ya un
bac vous êtes dans un break
vous sortez du break et vous savez quand
ils vont voir votre taille ils vont
comprendre que vous n'êtes pas une femme
mais un homme et ce qui est très
étonnant sur la culture talibane
c'est qu'à ce moment-là il n'ose pas
vous déshabillent et ses danseuses pas
déshabiller les femmes
moi j'ai refusé quand même quand je suis
sorti sur le battre je me suis accroupi
très vite de façon à dissimuler ma
taille effectivement et donc il avait
quelques doutes puisque j'étais avec gt
avec le confrère pakistanais qu'ils
avaient reconnu mais ils se sont donné
le ton de mme observé et puis finalement
ils ont quand même pas osé s'il était
était sûr à 70% ils me l'ont dit plus
tard mais c'est 30% restants ça les gêne
et donc ils ont demandé une vieille
femme de venir me de venir brouiller
donc la sauvage sans texter rapt et vise
à enlever la peau elle ad ailleurs et je
me suis pris un vieux coup de poing dans
le dans le
dans l'oreille qui m'a assommé et puis à
partir de là j'étais j'étais bien
saab était chaud et je me sente à l'aise
je suis en fait pas et alors là vous
êtes arrêté au départ c'est assez
courtois l'interrogatoire pourrait se
passe plutôt bien et la voyais arriver
un type qui s'appelle tu admires jawad
alors vous une description extradé dans
mon bouquin profil camus vip dédaigneuse
claudique mans et vous avez cette phrase
tout en lui révèle une adolescence
frustré de celles qui forment les
bourreaux inspiré serre vous sentez que
ce type a tellement souffert quand il
était petit qu'effectivement il déteste
la terre entière
et là vous commencez à vraiment flippé
il a 24 ans vous apprendra après c'est
un proche de ben laden qui a lu noire
importante d'al qaïda ouais c'est le
responsable des services secrets pour
l'ensemble du sud de l'afghanistan
considéré comme un jeune prodige c'est
vrai qu'il avait quelques qualités pas
dépourvue de cruauté il est responsable
de milliers d'arrestations arbitraires
de jalabad et de u2 probablement
plusieurs dizaines d'exécutions dont
celle du fameux commandant abdul haq way
qui est de ce commandant qui s'étaient
infiltrés en afghanistan pour tenter de
rallier les triples été tués tout de
suite qui a été tuée tout de suite parce
que à mon avis de l'été infiltré depuis
le départ alors vous départ des voleurs
dire que vous êtes journaliste vous
traite d'espions 1 1-10 même les
français peuvent être espion oui il y
avait une éclade déclarations
malencontreuses on peut pas leur en
vouloir mais dieu du ministère de la
défense qui avait dit nous avons des
espions en afghanistan je ne savais pas
je crois que c'était la veille
je viens dans quel sens qu'ils donnent
pas les photos à la télé au portable
donc j'étais un peu dans un bar oui
alors vous faites ce qu'on appelle un
city tour c'est-à-dire un tour de ville
vous étés que j b
vous êtes lapider quand même temps je
prends des pierres ma tête je prends des
pierres partout je n'ai pas été plus mal
lotis dans la mesure où j'étais debout
donc je me sens effectivement mais mon
un de mes confrères pakistanais qui se
trouvait à l'arrière et et recevez des
clés les coups de crosse des arabes
parce qu'en fait il est beaucoup
d'arabes jalalabad est
donc je crois que on est resté 26 jours
ensemble en prison il n'a pas pu dormir
pendant 21 jours ils y habitent et bleu
quoi et alors plus tard quand vous en
parlerais avec vos geôliers vous leur
direz pourquoi me faire faire ce tour de
la ville le bon comme arme
regardez je leur reproche en permanence
au city pourrait lui se disent ben oui
c'est normal qu'on vous fasse ça parce
que nous on n'a pas la télé pour
annoncer votre capture comment vous
voulez qu'on fasse
c'est insensé ils sont joueurs ouais
alors al'inverse de ce personnage et un
autre qui est beaucoup plus sympa dans
votre bouquin qui savaient le karité
hiver 1
alors lui il est sympathique d'emblée
vous le trouvez c'est bien dans ce
bouquin pascal le méchant le jury vous
le trouver sympathique d'emblée et puis
peut-être moins décérébrés par
l'islamisme que les autres il est temps
30 albanie un peu par hasard
et puis pour des pour des intérêts ainsi
il va c'est ça il est il est à ben moi
je le trouve assez sympa dans la mesure
où j'ai l'impression qui m'a sauvé la
vie
bah oui effectivement je alors y'a un
moment ça extraordinaire dans votre
bouquin c'est ça
et
c'est la sienne est absolument
incroyable on verra ça dans un film on
dirait deux scénaristes à prix de
l'acide
vous êtes là par les bombardements
américains les talibans étaient sur le
toit de la prison
et puis effectivement je j'ai dû penser
à abandonner se trouve que match a été
longtemps installé sur les
champs-elysées donc je devais avoir une
vieille nostalgie et je me suis mis à
fredonner mais alors malgré moi parce
que j'avais une pression pour une pour
joe dassin particulier aux champs
elysées et ils l'ont retenu il adore
chanter et c'est comme ça que joe dassin
entrée au panthéon de la gare les
survivants sur le toit de la prison les
avions américains dans le ciel les
talibans jubilant autant qu on les
frappe commence moi j'arrive au deuxième
jour des frappes
pour eux c'est tout bénef c'est la
guerre a commencé le djihad a commencé
donc il y avait une espèce de liesse
très particulière avec les tirs d'essai
à le spectacle était grandiose
quand vous entendez cette chanson
maintenant ça fait du bien quand même
non ça me rappelle des bons souvenirs
mais surtout je les entends du hadj à la
balle lorsque j'y suis retourné je crois
dans quelques années ça y est ma part
toujours 1 9 k l'histoire maintenant oui
vrai que je vois éventuellement prêt
doit alors vous découvrez les talibans
de l'intérieur et ça c'est très
intéressant c'est en ça que votre livre
aussi très intéressant c'est à dire que
finalement on voit des gens qui sont
capable d'autodérision qui on doit de se
moquer d'eux mêmes ils font ils sont
marrants son joueur je joue au volley
ball ils veulent constituer l'équipe des
talibans pour les jeux olympiques les
vrais méchants j'ai l'impression en
lisant votre bouquin c'est arabe sert
ceux qui sont venus et qui ont fait
souche là-bas quoi explique hélène c'est
la grée la vraie découverte c'est à dire
moi je suis arrivé plutôt confiant ce
même après l'arrestation je pensais que
je pouvais m'en sortir la mesure où vous
avez fréquenté en 96 ce que j'avais
complètement mésestimé c'était une
importance qui avait pris les arabes et
étrangers découverte les talibans les
craignez pas réellement ils en avaient
peur ils décrivent imprévisible
émotionnel alors pendant ce temps là
michel peyrard avec sérieux il ya une
grande mobilisation pour vous évidemment
votre journal paris match qui s'occupe
très bien de ces algues grand reporter
quand ils sont dans la merde il faut le
dire les autorités françaises aussi bien
sûr et vous vous en doutez pas si vous
êtes dans cette prison et puis vous
savez pas tout sur vous en doutez un
petit peu mais vous n'êtes pas vraiment
content doute même pas du tout je suis
je suis à ce point naïf que j'imaginais
on parle de libération c'est à dire à
partir du 12e jour j'imagine repartir
pas le même endroit très discrètement
par l' agence de mormant en remettant la
burqa pourquoi vous ont pas tué au début
j'ai il est excellent il était question
qui me tue le premier soir puisque quand
carine ever donc le directeur la prison
appel talus milan de djawad pour
demander mon shalwar kamiz donc la
tunique pakistanaise à ce moment là
j'étais
pratiquement jeté tortue je me jauger
par un tas de venir lui répond le
français est mort demain donc pas la
peine de le détient kaboul s'est opposé
à notre exécution des 2 ou 3 ieme jour
je crois qu'on le doit beaucoup à leurs
fans qui donc mon confrère pakistanais
qui avaient aidé des amitiés notamment
aux ministères des affaires étrangères
et à partir de ce moment là je crois que
notre vie n'est plus en danger
le top assez loin quand même c'est chaud
très chaud alors finalement les frappes
se précisant le 21 octobre à 22h la
prison des ménages mais pas des
journalistes
voilà comment ont été libérés et vous
serez libéré le lendemain